[Music]
Peppa
okay
um Shalom Whitney Cummings here I if you
hear a baby crying in the background
that's not what that is that's just my
inner monologue at this point we found a
way to mic it
um we have the iconic Amanda Knox here
today for round two round two gosh when
the world is in a very different place
and the studio is in a very different
place I see you have my uh cross stitch
thank you for representing it and by the
way actually round three because the
first one we broke into two parts right
because it was uh six it was longer than
your prisons actually
or at least felt longer yeah it was it
was a Joe Rogan Experience
they don't call me ho Rogan for Nothing
by the way since you have been uh on
this podcast you've been on Joe Rogan I
look Joe likes a lot Joe's when Joe
talks about someone when he's on a
different podcast it is a big like he
adores you oh well he was super nice I
we really clicked
um and you know I feel like he's just
the whole wrongful conviction thing is a
thing for him he gets it like he
understands the existential crisis of it
and so I really appreciate that it's not
somebody who trivializes it or is just
like oh you know whatever whatever they
just took four years of your life away
for no reason I guess it's really easy
to just go not my problem can't do
anything about look when Kim Kardashian
cares about something
that you know we when she cares about
anything besides herself you know this
is a problem
he was like I'm gonna take a day off
from doing photo shoots you're like
literally murdering people for things
they didn't do yeah but I also it's like
people I think sometimes with with
issues that are like not my backyard not
my problem where people are so busy they
have three jobs you know they have kids
like what am I gonna take on getting
people but like your son could be next
your daughter could be next and you're
creating people that when they come out
most of them don't come out like you and
start brilliant podcasts and advocate
for others you know when this happens
you know to most people they come out
and they're gonna actually be a problem
in society no like I mean there's yeah
there's a lot of struggles especially
because there's no like institutional
support for people who have been through
this experience like there's way more
support for people who have actually
committed crimes and then get out on
parole or whatever like they have
programs there aren't really programs in
place for people like us who are just
like oh oops now you're now you're free
for Rich actresses in Hollywood who were
hugged too long in a Christmas party but
not some people that were put in a cage
and also it's you know as someone who is
you know you know I don't want to say
psycho I don't want to pathologize
myself about it because I know the
reason I do it of you know being so
hardcore in Animal Welfare you know a
big reason I do it is not only because
it's the right thing to do we're also
animals but also when kids go to zoos
when they go to Sea World they're
learning at a very young age oh
voiceless things or to be exploited for
my benefits yeah this is a commodity
this exactly and so they learn how to
exploit etc etc but prisons are humans I
mean there's people that are like zoos
are wrong I'm like prisons have a lot of
people in there that are shouldn't be in
there also
yeah and especially now what would you
say about
um
it drives me nuts that now weed is
pretty much legal and there's still so
many people in prison for wheat like is
there a plan it's like this feels like
it should just be a sorry guys
here's whatever reparation but there's
it doesn't seem like there's any
movement on that it drives me nuts yeah
there's a hearing the sorry guys thing
is not something that happens very often
and people are really really hesitant to
do anything retroactively like there are
a lot of people who are trying to like
change laws like there's a law in
Washington that they're trying to change
right now where they make it illegal for
you to lie to children when you're
interrogating them so it is legal in the
United States to lie to somebody when
you're interrogating them they're trying
to make it at least illegal to not lie
to juveniles okay great
but they're not willing to apply that
retroactively to juveniles who have been
lied to in their interrogations in the
past is this like to give a pop culture
example do you remember that um that
show Making of a murderer yeah Brendan
dassey oh my God it makes me sick just
thinking about it and is that what you
mean like when they're trying to get
some kind of admission they can fly and
because as a kid all I did was Lie
With not being interrogated so imagine
if someone mislead you know yeah yeah
the the idea behind the the
justification for lying is as a legal
law enforcement professional we need to
use all the tools that we have at hand
in order to convince the person sitting
across from us that it is in their best
interest to confess to us the problem is
that in so many of these interrogation
scenarios when you lie to someone and
say we have evidence that places you at
the crime scene or we know because it's
like uh some you know someone testified
that they saw you commit the crime then
the person logically innocent or guilty
alike is going to start questioning
themselves and think is it possible that
I committed a crime and don't even
remember especially when they're telling
you you have amnesia and don't even
remember or they think logically no
one's going to believe me if some
witness is going to come up and say that
I did it so I might as well confess and
hopefully get off with a lesser sentence
like it's Common Sense stuff that people
don't really think about and I think
that that's one of the issues is that
when it comes to the criminal justice
system so much common sense is not
applied to the laws that we have in
front of us and most of us never have to
think about it because we're not in
these scenarios and the kind of people
that for the most part are responsible
for enforcing or do are underpaid it's
like it's like I you know I dated a
doctor for a while who it was in search
saw a lot of horrible stuff in an ER and
as I'm dating this guy I realize it's
not that he lacks empathy it's just he's
had to see so much horrible stuff that
his just bandwidth for horror has gone
down oh yeah so I mean I remember you
know look I was not the best at
communicating back then and I was very
embarrassed about having feelings or
being needy so there was a lot of like
how are you and I'd be like I'm fine
he'd be like great and I'm like how did
you not pick up on you know there's not
a lack of empathy but it's just sort of
there's a point where you have to get
desensitized so it's almost like the
very people that need to be the most
sensitive have had to become
desensitized and it's just like people
just kind of become numbers and it's
just like how do you
you know you know it's just so much
easier to just go like all right guilty
guilty guilt because when I think about
all these people that were selling weed
like what's the plan right well and
especially when you think like I'm
really glad you actually brought up
medical issues with this because you see
a similar thing across like the criminal
justice system and the medical system
because both are places where human
beings are pathologized like you like
anyone who's entering into those spaces
they're looking for the problem they're
looking for the problem in you as a
human being they're not looking at what
works they're not looking they're they
they get used to seeing problems and not
being able to read that potentially
they're the problem more like there's
something wrong with like what the the
context of the situation so
yeah like I think a lot of well not a
lot of medical professionals are
starting to reconsider the idea that
perhaps when they have a client come to
them they shouldn't just think what is
wrong with you how do I diagnose you
with something that's wrong with you
um that's one problem but also in the
criminal justice system it's not just
treating everyone like they're a problem
right and that they're an obstacle and
you have to crack that nut right and
instead and that in that it puts you in
this position of not trusting these
authorities that you ultimately rely on
people like you that are as smart as you
incisive as you you know sagacious is
you I always love to ask this question
about what you've learned about human
nature through this
you know the trauma and you know um and
and now what you're exposing yourself to
um in terms of um helping make change
there's something in um animal rescue uh
that's called founder syndrome it's in a
lot of Charities as well that's
basically when you start with you know a
good intention I'm Gonna Save animals
I'm gonna help kids with cleft palates
I'm gonna help with addiction
you start off with great intentions uh
and then you you know people start
telling you you're so amazing and you
know and you you're such a saint and
you're getting these donations and you
are you know making a difference but
then you sort of it starts to affect
your frontal lobe a little bit you know
who knows whether you know I'm sure
nature nurture you know plays a role uh
adrenaline addiction whatever and then
all of a sudden these people that
started you know what happened here in
La at a place called Wildlife Way
Station where this woman
um was paying herself 90 a month out of
the donations there was no water on the
premises she was relying on free you
know volunteers and stuff to do
everything was working them insane hours
and then they you know see what's going
on but then once you see how horrific
that you don't want to leave so it's
like zookeepers there's a lot of a
really amazing zookeepers who knows zoos
are bad but they're like if I leave it's
gonna be even worse you know so it's but
the person at the top something has
corrupted their brain whether it's power
I'm not smart enough to know what it is
I do know um you know just the history
of Comedy is something I'm you know
hopefully know a little something about
you know it obviously started in America
stand-up comedy is uniquely American but
the idea of the Court Jester you know
even back then they knew before you know
Andrew huberman and science they knew
there's something about if someone can't
laugh at themselves power has corrupted
their brain in some capacity right so
the Joker's job was to try to make them
laugh and make fun of them right and if
the king didn't laugh there was like
something wrong right so I love that
once in the wild and so
um so I'm curious like what you're
saying is like feels like the same thing
where you get in to help people and then
all of a sudden it just becomes a job
you're underpaid you have to get
desensitized there's a certain point
where you think like you know have you
gleaned anything just about human nature
in general and maybe we kind of already
said it about sort of uh you know I
think because you've been through it the
fire in you will never die because you
know what it feels like but have you
seen just in working with people like
clean something about just like human
nature that
doesn't have to be discouraging for me
I'd rather just know the truth you know
but just curious any insights I mean I
I've read a wise quote recently which
was something along the lines of those
who believe that they are the most
righteous are the ones who are most
likely to commit the most harm there you
go so like if you firmly firmly believe
without question that your cause is the
righteous one you are willing you
unconsciously are willing to harm and
cut you know cut corners and break the
rules and dehumanize people in the
process in order to achieve your
righteous end and so questioning
yourself asking yourself at every moment
in time
how can how could I be wrong every one
of us is wrong at some point and
constantly sort of reflecting just
having a moment of pause and being like
what am I wrong about right now I know
I'm wrong about something it'd be weird
if you weren't I mean most science is
debunked every couple years I mean it's
like you know when I dated a doctor he'd
said it's called a practice for a reason
we're practicing this is not the
championship
patients are called patience we need you
to be patient you know
[Laughter]
for me to tell you that you're on your
period for every problem you have you
know so it's that's that's so I see that
so much and I'll just speak for kind of
the woke Justice Warrior you know kind
of charlatans in in my field where their
whole thing is like you know about you
have to say this and you have to use
this word you have to use this it's like
you don't see that you're bullying other
people with your
self-righteous indignation cause like
how do you not see this but you're
justifying being a meanie Yeah by saying
well I'm protecting other people like
who bitch
yeah do you see the person next to you
is the person like especially when when
everyone's so divorced of the people
that they're actually having the impact
with it's like when you're actually
engaging with human beings what is the
impact you're having like how are you
making people feel and I think people
lose sight of that like we've lost sight
of just interconnectedness and like the
actual impact of our actions because
we're spending so much time in this
abstract space and this like theoretical
idea of what's right and what's wrong
instead of like really sitting with you
know like what's right and what's wrong
really depends a lot on the human beings
that are in front of us and how they're
interacting with each other
um I think that people are complicated
and I think that issues are complicated
and so when you treat them in these
really really strict black and white
this is how it is and this is how it
isn't ways of thinking you're just
inevitably going to be like charging
rampaging over people's feelings and
experiences and all the people that
think they're the most right are always
the people that are like news is fake
and you're like then how are you right
there's nothing's true so how could you
not you know it's like that you know the
same thing where it's like you know we
kind of have to question everything even
like some science stuff these days as
someone that I've talked about this
before I was in focus groups when I was
broke you know I would go to UCLA and be
like are you depressed come do this sure
yes for 50 bucks cash I am depressed
also even if I wasn't before walking up
to a depression study for cash is I am
now and I would say what I had to say to
get called back to come to more studies
so if you were like a good pupil Tracy
flick and these stuff you know I did
them for Neutrogena and L'Oreal and yeah
they're probably gonna sue me I have
umbrella Insurance
um but uh you know I would go in and I
would get feedback on stuff and you
would they'd be like what are the side
effects do you have a headache I'd be
like yes I do have it thank you for
reminding me and you say what you have
to say and it's like you know so I just
not to say that all science but
everything you know most science is
mostly white kids in colleges yeah these
studies you know or it's the ones I was
in was a lot of meth heads who needed 50
bucks very quickly you know so it's like
so for any of us to think we're right
about anything it's just it's you're
embarrassing yourself you know and
um but yeah I think though there is
something whether it's religious shame
whether it's you know you know the
theory about why public speaking is so
afraid uh terrifying for people is
because you know on epigenetic level if
you know thousands of years ago in
tribal times you were speaking in front
of people that meant you were making
your case in front of the tribe who yeah
you would not sir you know yeah you're
public speaking in a second exactly so
it's like I'm I am fascinated by this
new you know and I'm so grateful that
you did the roast we'll talk about in a
second because to me the roasts are all
about you know shame release and they're
all about being able to say like yeah
I've made mistakes yeah who hasn't like
yeah I've well you haven't
you got the punishment I should have had
and vice versa but um I do have a bit
about how I feel like you would survive
very well in prison dude I would be
running shoes
I feel like you would have rested
control from the warden because the
warden be like oh wait no she can like
I've seen you produce a comedy special
and it's like no no like if you can
heard a whole bunch of comedians in the
line between like criminal and comedian
is like serious is is the line is just
cocaine it's a line of cocaine laced
with fentanyl
like I feel like I would have greatly
benefited from you being in my prison
because I would have been scared as hell
of you at first but then I would have
seen that you would have had shit
organized and I would have been like yes
commander tell me what to do this show
is sponsored by betterhelp and thank God
I mean reading these ads every week has
honestly had been therapy for me it
reminds me that I really you know you
know they say in uh 12-step programs
your head is a bad neighborhood don't go
in there alone okay it's easy to get
caught up in what everyone else needs
from you and never take a moment to
think about what you need from yourself
you know me never thinking about myself
uh but when we all spend all of our time
giving to others it can leave us stretch
too thin you might get stretch marks
which is a real impetus to get your shit
together you feel burned out therapy can
give you the tools to find a more
Balanced Life so that you can keep
supporting others without leaving
yourself behind you gotta put your
oxygen mask on before you put it on the
person next to you who knew Southwest
flight attendants had so much freaking
wisdom they're not just talented
comedians anymore if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible suited to your
schedule just even if it's not suited to
your schedule fit it in because I've
found that when I'm not taking care of
my brain I call it just going to the
brain gym the same way you would take
care of your body the same way you would
um you know go to the gym for your
muscles in your body your brain is also
a muscle and the more you think negative
thoughts the more you spend time in the
future worrying or the past regretting
you're not going to work the muscle of
being in the present fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com Whitney today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
hlp.com Whitney being a mess is out
comedians are going to therapy now
what's your excuse
I think there's something for me I'll
just speak for myself that was very
um freeing realizing people thought I
was a bitch where
you don't have to worry about people
thinking you're a bitch you know and I
think just like you know doing a I guess
traditionally kind of honestly stand up
is not a masculine it's male dominated
but it's not a traditionally masculine
it's it's men complaining and talking
about their feelings and talking about
their depression that is the most group
of people you're appropriating a
Womanhood okay this is not a masculine
art it's man being like Oh my God my
heart broken and you're like that's not
dating it's hard that's our thing that's
what we do it's pillow talk yeah like
complaining and you know making people
listen to you that's a woman thing
um but so I think that once you know and
I think that in the beginning you know
being on stage I felt like I had to be
so much tougher you know I was so scared
I was so um uh I just felt like I had to
be really hard because I always wanted
the comedians in the back to respect me
or be scared of me whatever what does it
feel like to be hard making jokes
like I don't even know what that is what
do you mean say it again like well you
were like you had to be tough on stage
like what does that mean I just felt
like I had to be a little scary
um you know because I felt like I was so
scared and I find usually this most
scared people are the scariest like it
took me the longest time to realize that
anger is just sadness stuff you know so
it's like when someone's like there's
projecting yeah you it's like a small
dog that has to like bark a lot you know
you have to make people think that
you're
um a force to be reckoned with because
you're so not and I think you're just so
fucking fragile yeah and then I'd
probably just see adrenaline and you
know I had only really watched you know
I had seen Ellen I had seen Sarah
Silverman but I wanted to so badly not
to copy any women or you know they also
were you know had honed who they were by
then so I was mostly watching guys so I
was like I just need to be this you know
and I wanted to make sure that I never
seemed like I was trying to be sexy or
flirty or the last thing I ever wanted
were you know cute I was I was
projecting because as an insecure girl
at that time the idea of going to a
comedy club with my man and then a girl
being like you know flirty or whatever
you know so I always wanted the girls to
I just wanted to de-gender myself right
really you know and I probably didn't
know my own power at the time I felt
like I had to you know really show
people how tough I was but it already
came through I just wasn't super
self-aware and so um uh I don't know
where I'm going with this but I have
turned into Joe Rogan I'm just talking
about comedy 20 years ago at this point
um you were talking about public
speaking well just oh in general like
you know I think that um people want to
be led I think for me it really helped
the Equine Therapy I do working with
herds and prey animals because the lead
mare you know the female lion if you
look at um the animal the animals that
are matriarchies you know um Chicana
Birds orca whales Lions bees they're the
most successful species for the most
part and it's nothing negative to the
man it's not like fuck man no it's like
you guys sleep all day you need more
energy you're making sperm you're doing
your thing like you serve your purpose
but the women for the most part Warriors
the women you know sort of like do more
and I think that when you say matriarchy
I think people men are like you don't
know we just just let us do more of the
aggressive shit we have more to defend
we're more vulnerable so we're going to
be more vicious in a lot of ways
um and so I think that working with prey
animals really helped me because what I
do something called agala and Liberty
training with rehabilitating abused
horses is that you learn that they they
want you to be Regal they want you to
have pride they don't want you to be
apologetic because then they're like
well then who's in charge here yeah like
I'm freaking out like what is people
just want for the most I don't think
people want to be patronized and have
Draconian rules for no reason but I
think for the most part people are so
afraid of hurting someone's feelings or
seeming like a bitch that were vague and
we're unclear and that's what makes
people anxious and stressed out if
you're the leader you gotta lead if
you're not shut the fuck up and do what
the leaders saying right but I think if
you've decided I'm going to be in charge
of I did really learn this when I was
first booked a couple like movies and a
director one time came over to the
actors the two lead actors very strong
personality comedy guys and he was like
so what do you guys think we should
shoot next and I just watched the actors
just be like
they're vulnerable they're putting
themselves on me and they're just like
and it was over at that point they're
like all right we're doing this we're
doing the director was just like why
won't they I'm like dude you fucking
gave them your power they're here they
signed up for you to lead them and then
you it's like someone driving a car
being like how do you where do you think
we should go and I was like can you
fucking want I lost my trust in you yeah
you know I don't think anyone it's
taking me a long time to realize you're
not gonna think I'm a bitch as long as
it's coming from the right place and I'm
not just doing this to be sadistic or
like for power totally totally yeah like
the feeling micromanaged is definitely
something that you do not want but like
feeling having faith that the person who
is who you're looking to for guidance is
actually going to give you guidance and
not be ambiguous for sure totally it's a
great parenting idea well we're gonna
talk about parenting in a second because
you are on your second baby and
um I need to re-parent myself
um but I do want to ask on that note I
just wrote this down because when you
talked about lying to kids I was
thinking about this recently and all the
things that made me distrust adults
are we to are we still doing Santa I
know so I I just look if you're gonna
lie to your kid about Santa and the
Easter Bunny like don't drag me into it
yeah yeah I just I am very anti-lying to
kids
um I don't think that it's necessary
I've read a lot of um so now that I'm
I've read a lot of you know parenting
books at this point and you'd be
surprised how many of them are like just
lie to them just like if they're if your
kid doesn't want to go to sleep just
tell them oh I'll go get you some a
bottle and then they don't come back
they know you're lying to them like you
don't need to lie to your kid in order
to talk to them I felt it as a kid I it
was a lot because I have two friends
that are actors and they'll fight they
were going through a rough time and then
they would say to the kid like oh we
were just acting we were working on a
scene and I was like
the kids first of all you're insulting
yourself that you think you had such a
dumb kid that doesn't can't you feel it
I remember as a kid you know feeling
tension feeling tension in the air being
like is everyone okay they're like no
we're good we're good and I was just
like it made me feel like I must be
crazy because the idea of thinking your
primary caretakers are lying to you it's
too it's gaslighting yeah so then I was
like I guess I must be nuts and then you
stop trusting your intuition and then
you get into trouble when you're a
teenager yep yep yep yep
so no we're not doing Santa we're not
doing Tooth Fairy no I'm not going to
lie to my kids about where their
presents come from
um also this is so funny so funny I was
talking to Rick Rubin on his podcast and
I was asking him like are you telling
your kid about Santa and he's like it's
so funny you just said that because we
did the thing
Santa gave these presents and he the kid
wakes up it's like freaking out he's
like there was a man in our house
you just let a man in the house and then
all of a sudden they were like uh we
didn't what a real weird the whole thing
is you don't talk to strangers you don't
talk to men you don't sit on man's lap
and then here we are once a year oh and
also the people who bring their kids to
Santa and like Santa and the kid clearly
does not want to sit on Santa's lap and
is like screaming and he doesn't want to
inhale whiskey at 2AM and like if your
kid doesn't want to sit on fucking
Santa's life like what are you doing
torturing you want to get a photo like
that's what you want you want this
experience of your kid to be like I
don't understand the whole forcing kids
to do anything that they actually don't
want to do either
um I don't know I'm kind of a
hippy-dippy parent that way I don't
think that's what that is I think like I
think there's these
what's the word like rituals or
something that that that almost these
cult-like rituals where it's like here's
the photo with Santa I must be a good
parent I took it to the pumpkin patch
right right I had a friend of mine's kid
come to my um where my horses are and I
had a very clear idea of how I wanted
the day to go I was like though I had
the horse the baby's gonna your baby it
was whatever four or five and I was like
you can come see the mini ponies then
I'm gonna show them the tortoise and
talk all about dinosaurs and I had this
whole plan for the day of all these
animals there were baby goats and the
whole thing is the pond and I was like
We'll go on the little boat on the pond
and then the kid comes and he just wants
to freaking climb trees and pick up poop
and I'm like no no we're gonna and I'm
like no that's what I wanted the kid to
do yeah I wanted him having a photo next
to the whore like that's my ego that's
my shit yep yeah I wanted to see my
coolest friend ever that got a photo and
also and then when you have that energy
if you're forcing something it prey
animals they just move away from you
they want nothing to do with it because
at the end it just boils down to fear
I'm afraid I'm not going to get this
photo I'm afraid I'm not going to get
this moment I'm afraid I'm you know and
the kid's just happy as shit yep playing
with trash yep he just wants to walk
across this dangerous as hell little
bridge and I'm like this is what we're
doing yeah what was that
um I again projection like you have your
own visions of the way this of things
that you would have liked and that's
what I would have enjoyed but I'm 40.
yes well clearly you need to pet a baby
goat
I want to give them the childhood I
would have wanted or something it was
also and I see parents doing this I see
parents putting their kids in baseball
I'm like baseball is the most boring
like what kid wants to just sit stand in
an outfield and wait to miss a ball
it's true
you just don't want your kid to get in
the dirty or get in the mud or do some
other you know why would a kid want to
stand in the sun in an outfield just
waiting for a ball that it's gonna miss
and everyone's gonna yell at him yeah
that's a really good point I mean I'm
I'm trying to think of all these
different alternative ways of doing
things and a lot of them is just like
following Eureka's like what Eureka's
interests are and a lot of time like now
right now she's super into animals and
so I'm trying to teach her to be really
smart and thoughtful about animals like
approach with the like back of the hand
and just but I'm following her like and
paying attention to her will you
extrapolate on that with the back of the
hand because this is like a game I can't
believe everyone doesn't do this so I
don't understand maybe again because
people treat animals like Commodities
but
they have knives in their head if they
have knives in their head and they and
you don't know what like their history
is they might have trauma where they
don't trust anybody else but their owner
like if they're in my home they
definitely have that yeah so like when I
the way that I've been teaching Eureka
to interact with animals is that you
have to approach giving very clear signs
of like your interest but not just like
first of all you ask if it's not your
animal you ask the person who is who has
the animal can we approach the animal
and we say please and then if they say
yes then we approach with back of the
hand first and then open hand we note
grab the big thing is no grabby and no
and and horses especially this drives me
nuts because horses and dogs
um because I see these awful injuries I
used to date a vet and it's always like
kid and you look at a kid who just hits
a dog on the head and you're just like
and the parents like how so I've seen
kids like grab dogs and throw them and
I'm just like that is not a toy and
they're like what are you doing that
drives me nuts when people do the
rhetorical question it's like or like
I've told this story before but I saw
this woman it it I don't use the word
trigger a lot but let's just say it it
um uh what did it do activated me
um I saw this uh child probably four or
five years old in a grocery store the
mom is obviously overwhelmed frustrated
I can't I you know I can't relate to
that I you know but the the child would
put cereal sugary cereal that because
they put sugar cereal in the lowest too
on purpose yep and they pay extra for
them and then all the candy is right
there next to where you pay so they have
to touch all the candy yeah five or once
it's at five feet it's like the grape
nuts and the bullshit you know but
they're very you know smart about where
they put it so the kid is putting like
the Lucky Charms in the cart and then
the mom puts it back and then the kid
puts it back in and then the mom just
snapped it was like put put put the
cereal in the car one more time see what
happens see what happens do it
and I'm just like
I'm going nuts because I just as a child
I feel like I had such indirect passive
aggressive bullshit like that like and I
I I hate myself for doing this because
when I see people giving parenting
advice when someone I was with a
girlfriend of mine once and we were at a
coffee shop and she was holding her baby
and uh a woman just walked by and went
you better put some sunscreen on that
baby
and I also like how do you know that the
baby doesn't have sex I literally got I
was like what are you I couldn't help it
and I was like stop fighting with this
there's no point
um but I said to the woman I was like I
just don't think your child understands
sarcasm it was like you saw how confused
the child was and I just saw myself in
that moment because I spent so much of
my childhood being so confused people
would say I love you but then they'd be
screaming we'd go to church which was
all about being gracious and that it
would be you know so it just like drove
me nuts but I don't think anyone wants
to do this intentionally but I think
that when when women talk about it or
man whatever and just give permission to
you know like you don't have to be
perfect no one wants that like no you
know I have a friend it's a mom who
she'll lose her temper and she'll be
like I just lost my temper yeah and I
shouldn't have done that yeah I'm sorry
and the kid's like okay cool but to go
like what that didn't happen yeah yeah
yeah that I think is the key thing is
like you have to model for your kid what
what even processing emotions is and so
like you you and like you can't be
perfect you're never going to be perfect
so you're going to like the way that I'm
trying to teach Eureka is it's like she
knows when I'm upset like she and I
don't like yell at her should most
likely what's happening is something in
the world is making me upset and I'll
like you know I might ask you to do a
roast
it's stressful I might be having like I
still deal with panic attacks so like
there's things are happening and then we
like sit down we do a lot of breathing
together like if she's having a moment
or if I'm having a moment we just sort
of like sit and breathe deeply together
um those kinds of strategies but I think
you're right like just owning up like
acknowledging what happened don't
pretend that something don't Gaslight
your kid is basically the the thing and
like be clear
um one thing that I've read that's
really really been super helpful with
Eureka is don't say no say what the
consequences are so like if you pull on
a DOT if you grab a dog it's owie like
it's very very clear it's not no because
no is just well why the the the thing
that is understood is owie something
hurts and we know what hurting is like
it's owie so like we don't want to do
that or if you um if you are gonna fall
down the stairs it's like okay let's
slow owie fall like those kinds of
things convey to the kid what they need
to process in order to understand what
to do yeah because the kid's brain
doesn't naturally go there when you're
like don't go down the stairs like why
is there something down there I
shouldn't have is this right stop for me
or are you just telling me something for
the sake of telling me something because
I'm living my life here
when I was a kid if you told me no that
was like a Surefire way to get me to
want to do it even more exactly and if I
didn't do it in that moment I'd wait
till I was out of your sight and then
I'd be like what's this know about why
is this so off limits now like I'm way
more interested in this totally you know
it's interesting um and real quick just
about when I see so many kids get bitten
by horses
um and when people are like let's take
the kid it's like it's just me nuts
because it's someone that is like you
know is a very intense relationship with
rehabilitating horses I uniquely know
how dangerous they can be especially
because so many people feed them so they
get a lot of times when they bite it's
just because idiots feed them too much
you should never give treats to horses
especially if they're not yours and um
so they get bitey but also horses have
their eyes are on the side of their
heads they're not on the front right so
people always go in straight to their
head and it's confusing to them you know
like you always go in on you know the
side if you're gonna do it but you for
ask permission move forward you know and
it's like it just drives me nuts when I
see these people they're like well horse
is a horse bit my kid I'm like that is
your fault
I don't know how else to say it the
horse was being a horse it's like when
it's like Chris Rock said about when the
um when the Orca whale at Sea World
killed the trainer uh or no I'm sorry it
was um when uh said Friedan words tiger
uh stragged she was like yeah no the the
tiger didn't the tiger just finally
figured out it was a tiger like it
didn't you know it wasn't an asshole
that's how it's always been it was just
like the drugs were off or whatever
um but let's talk really quick
um about the roast so so when I was
putting together the people that I
wanted to be on the roast again you know
uh comedy it's a wild time where I don't
know if you deal with this on your
podcast or on YouTube or whatever but
things are so censored now and and it's
not even like trying to be silenced and
a lot of it is just because you know um
Instagram is now owned by Facebook you
know apple is now it's you know Fox and
Hulu is Disney you know it's just like
these corporations that are taking over
and buying everything
um YouTube now even if it's not like if
you say something about Q Anon whatever
they just have a spider program that
sees Q Anon even if you're like this is
wrong and here's why you know even if
you're not saying I support Q Anon those
are facts like it just takes you out of
the algorithm demonetizes you and so
Comedy Central is effectively gone
there's no place to really do uncensor
comedy and not that I'm trying to say
crazy crit you know it's it's censored
in a way that's not even sensible and
you're the first person to say like yeah
we don't need to say women are old we
don't need to do like this racist shit's
gross we don't need to talk about
periods
why did that okay
um that paid for my last house um you
know but so I just I think that the
roasts always serve this this really
important purpose of like a shame
release kind of yeah a catharsis of
shaming yourself being able to laugh at
yourself and seeing that like you can
own your mistakes and it's not the end
of the world if you did something dumb
totally you did something silly and you
know because right now we're at this
place where it's like everyone is held
accountable for a tweet they sent when
they were 15 and didn't know better and
oh of course their Halloween costume
that was misguided when they were 18 is
now going to haunt them for the rest of
their life hey y'all booty Bo
sounds funny doesn't it having it not so
much okay that's why I'm excited to tell
you about Lumi the world's best whole
body deodorant it's clinically proven to
control odor ER wear your pits your
privates and Beyond the crevices the
nooks the crannies for a whopping 72
hours as an OB GYN lumi's founder Dr
Shannon klingman met thousands of women
concerned with the odor below the belt
through clinical testing she discovered
it wasn't the vagina to blame so stop
with the sushi jokes stop with the trout
joke stop with the wharf jokes okay but
it's bacteria on the skin so she created
Lumi a pH optimized aluminum free
deodorant that actually works and works
everywhere with over 150
000 five-star reviews to prove it
clinically proven to block odor all day
in control odor for up to 72 hours
lumi's starter pack is perfect for new
customers it comes with a solid Stick
deodorant I have it I've been using the
coconut one oh my God it smells so good
look at this look at this I'm wearing a
special tank top just to show you guys
the deodorant I'm putting it on my pits
right now but you got to put it like
right below the tush sometimes I get
that boob sweat you put it kind of in
the crevices kind of next to the crevice
you know what I'm talking about there's
two other free products of your choice
that come with it this one I have the
body wash is what they sent me and then
these deodorant wipes I go through a
pack of these truly a day I put on the
back of my neck my lower back you're
gonna get free shipping uh as a special
offer for listeners new customers get
five dollars off a Lumi starter pack
with code Whitney at Lumi l-u-m-e
deodorant.com that equates to over 40
off your starter pack when you visit
lumideodorant.com and use the code
Whitney I heard there was some guy that
you know like Facebook memories oh
absolutely yeah Facebook like even
Google photos has memories like oh 15
years ago this is what you were doing
yeah and someone guy I'm sure it's
happened more than once but a guy got
fired because his Halloween costume like
popped up I don't know if he was Native
American Indian who knows what the hell
it was
um but um so it's kind of just showing
like we're all in perfect we're all
flawed and the fact that comedians are
the ones that are leading the charge of
like you know sanity in terms of you
know being able to forgive yourself or
forgive others whatever all of us human
beings yeah and so it was like I was
always about you know just being
comedians because I think the Comedy
Central roast they got really sideways
when it was just like putting in random
celebrities that were just there because
they were famous like you know Pam
Anderson like you know I've that always
ate me up that that you know and not not
that she can't do it it just was you
know
I see it as like verbal MMA the original
like verbal MMA and if you're putting
heavyweights against featherweights it's
gonna be nasty it's gonna be cringy it's
just you know me posing against her in a
swimsuit competition that's gonna be a
little rusty
ugly
it's gonna be brutal so same same and
you could tell she was her you could
tell a lot of the people on it it was
and you know the energy that we had at
ours where it felt like all equals like
you know everyone was having a good time
yeah yeah that was super good you know
and so and I also had like 40 year old
women aren't old let's not do guys with
small dicks that's why they kill us
let's just not to call men pedophiles
for no reason because there actually are
the you know and so to me it was like
and it's about Reinventing yourself and
being like you know what I don't have to
be the person I had to be forever yes I
had 500 hair colors in the pandemic and
everyone thought I was on fentanyl
whatever like and I can just make fun of
it and we can move on and I just like
you not only being a you know close
friend of mine but also what you've been
through I'm like who deserves more of a
opportunity to show what they can do
who's been like trapped like you know I
remember thinking last time I met you
being like you're still in prison in a
lot of ways and it just drives me nuts
and I felt like this would be such a
great opportunity to show because you're
so effervescent and funny and quit and
I'm like but I only see you when you're
having to be somber and talk about all
this stuff you know so it was like was
it fun was it oh my God it's scary I was
so fucking thrilled that you let me be a
part of it because one I love comedy
um I use comedy a lot to just like
grapple with the existential crisis of
being a human being in the world and the
absurdity of the world that so often we
we encounter and instead of taking it
all super seriously we can also just
shake it off and have a laugh so I find
it really therapeutic but what often
happens is when I try to share like a
quip or make a joke about something very
often people get really offended just
because it's coming from me and they
associate me with tragedy with something
very serious and they tell me that I'm
not allowed to make jokes because in
their minds I live in this world of True
Crime and therefore there's nothing to
joke about and one
there's always something to joke about
yeah
and two
um I don't live inside someone else's
head I live in my
in my own head and I'm processing my
experience in my own way and I am
entitled to do that so I feel like you
giving me that opportunity was insane
first of all I feel really really lucky
um I know that there are many people who
would have loved that opportunity and so
I'm super super grateful to you it's
actually really inspired me to want to
do do more so that makes me we should
chat about that but yeah it's
like being able only problem what is
that the sick irony is that
when you go on stage and make people
laugh
it's called murdering or killing I know
I know and then I'm drinking this liquid
death and it's like murder your thirst
and it's like everyone's throwing around
murder so and it's like yep liquid death
in comedy it's the most horrific thing
and you know and it's in in comedy like
I've always thought oh she belongs with
us you know
um because you know comedians it's it's
we're in this wild time where comedians
are getting and I we don't have to talk
about me like come for me as much as you
want like I'll be fine but you know it's
so fascinating when people like
comedians that come from tragedy and
Trauma right and they're all depressed
and suicidal and you're like kind of and
then you know two minutes later they're
like you're punching down you're causing
violence like comedians are bullies and
you're just like pick a lane like people
can't make up their minds with us
especially with female comedians we're
like the I always say the most hated
species of of women on the planet
because it's like you know it's it's I
think people feel very safe being able
to be rough with us because they assume
we're tougher than everyone we're
stronger than everyone we did you know
and I think people kind of do that with
you too where they're sort of like it
it's like what made you think that
Amanda Knox can just take anything what
made you think that like more lashings
need to be taken like what made you
think that I and how to like I need to
be put in my place like what is the
place that you think I need to be put
yeah you were on vacation in Italy for
four months just living the Vita logo
and so um you know and I also think that
that that being perceived publicly in
any way is sexual and being either
Unapologetic about it or you know as
comedians you always as female comedians
you this is a generalization you tend to
start talking about sex it's something
that relates to everyone it's something
that I mean that's something you bring
up with your in your roast it's like if
ever if the only reason anyone wants to
talk to you is because they want to fuck
you then yeah you're going to end up
talking about sex a lot what do you want
me to talk about politics yeah I know
you love it when women do that at 24 is
the only thing I knew about and it's the
thing that caused me the most stress and
shame and you know to me comedy is very
much of a shame release and it's like
people put shame on me all day okay and
then I gotta go on stage and like
release it all you know and so
um I just think you have so much to say
you're I mean I you know look if someone
that was worked really really hard to
get you know funny it's it really
watching you just going like to be able
to alchemize and sublimate trauma into
into this will it helped that you like
helped write the jokes
[Laughter]
you know but it was just so um it was so
you know I forgot I think how you know
people that have trauma can can just
more easily if you choose humor you know
you're just gonna be funnier and it's
just like a a weird gift that came from
your nightmare oh yeah choosing choosing
to be grateful choosing to find the
absurdity in this situation you you
asked me a question earlier about
um what do I think about human nature
and especially in these like authority
figures who are just committing all of
these wrongs and like one of the things
that I've learned is that
people who are in these positions of
power in positions of authority believe
they're a certain kind of person and so
they're incapable of doing something
wrong and that puts someone like me in
the position of feeling incredibly
gaslit
and it's so it's like it's so absurd
that it becomes funny and like you're
you you see the world in this like
really really clear way of like oh my
God you're just like you just and I get
it we all want to be good people we all
like have our good intentions we and all
of that
and it's it's just like in because
you've never asked yourself am I wrong
about this I'm now forcing somebody into
this box that I've built for them this
cage that I've built for them and I'm
telling them that they're the ones who
built the cage like it's yeah and it's
just it's so dumb it's like so gaslighty
that it's funny and when you because you
what else are you gonna do if you'll
blow your brains out if you don't laugh
about it it's like laughter's just like
a tension release and it's just and I
feel like so many people are sleeping on
the medicine of laughter because they're
so when I need to take myself seriously
like what are you doing kids are eating
Tide Pods and 380 people have died
taking selfies falling off a cliff like
it's awful but you just happens you have
to laugh you have to what else is there
it's on there you'll never stop crying
and something you just said about like
people want to be good or whatever and I
think people associate good with being
right but this day and age how can
anyone be right like I am so my new Kink
is saying I don't
[Laughter]
as soon as you start doing comedy you're
a lesbian that's how it works it's
always what happens you're almost
wearing shoulder pads
um but it's just how would I know like
how and also like I I have a couple
phrases now because I find myself always
feeling like I need to have an opinion
you know there's just pressure now you
know it's like and you know I don't have
enough information to weigh in yet I
don't have enough information and then
when people want to gossip about
somebody because gossip is another thing
that really I find well it communes us
we can all just use that person as
something that gets us closer and we
don't feel better about it serotonin
from it it bonds us it also gives you a
little hit of you know judging people
but I know what's ha it just it makes me
feel I'm at this point I know I'm gonna
feel like shit after it makes me feel
dirty and makes me feel gross but I can
always just say like I don't know enough
about this person to be able to weigh in
and I see people kind of go like oh
you're not taking the bait and just
talking shit but then they go like oh
that's an option this people that I have
the most respect for say I don't know I
the um Grace who you met who works with
me now is a producer the second day on
the job
when she was my assistant she I don't
know what was happening she had just
maybe stop and get something and I was
like oh did you get the thing and she's
like I forgot and I was like
I'm promoting you yeah because you just
said you forgot you didn't make up some
lie you weren't filled with shame it's
she's German too
um that'll do it that'll do it I was
like thank you so that like just seeing
someone say I forgot instead of oh no um
I got that they're running late just
some bullshit nonsense and she doesn't
know something she's like I don't know
and I'm like I would have thought I
would have gotten fired if I said I
didn't know something I thought I would
be less than I would be stupid something
the smartest people say I don't fucking
know how would I
well some people do get fired for doing
that and I think that's the problem is
we're incentivizing people in the wrong
way same thing with the criminal justice
system same thing with like even in
medical diagnoses I think like people
want to sit like I remember when Eureka
was born
um they told us that she was
um she had this like horrible
debilitating disease
when I tell you about that okay so I
have nightmares about this a uh from the
way I remember is using she has this
horrible like brain eating degenerative
disease or it's just rosacea yeah or
it's just a skin condition so just watch
her yeah so so we're gonna put her in an
MRI machine when she's not even a day
old and we're gonna like plug you know
things on her head and you have to come
back in two months and do the like we're
gonna strobe light her to see if she has
crazy seizures and I remember thinking
because this was so I called a couple
friends of mine to ask about this
because I was like I think we're taking
legal action like I never think like
that because I was like I cannot think
of a more stressful thing not that
you're not going to be watching your
baby anyway but to like I think it was
like look for signs to see if anything
oh yeah she's a baby yeah she's just a
little worm and like Chris was sitting
there holding her being like okay is she
is she just sort of like twitching in
her sleep or is she having a seizure I
don't know I don't know and what am I
creating that wasn't there in the first
place because I'm stressing out about
this thing yeah I'm crying every day for
the first two months of my child's life
oh wait it's just a skin condition that
I find out six months later so can I ask
you about that because I was thinking
this must be because I find more and
more when I go to the doctor they have
to do run the game do you think it's
because of so many malpractice lawsuits
or how litigious people are that they
just have to cover all their bases
probably
um yeah I think they probably are taking
the tack of we're gonna give you the bad
news and if it comes out better than
that you're going to be grateful instead
of psychologically you're good we're
gonna tell you it's okay and then it
turns out not okay and then you're gonna
you know file lawsuits against us that
would be my guess because yes she will
have a brain condition if her mom is
crying over her crib for the first two
years yeah I'm like breastfeeding her
it's like weeping
so I don't know it's was there anything
that you learned in the um the birth of
the process of Eureka that you will
apply to the second if we will do this
we won't do this in terms of birth plan
stuff like that you know we deep dived
um into this on our podcast
um tell us the name of it labyrinths
nice oh you did algorithm but you did
you did um because is that a separate
baby podcast or it's within no it's just
like a mini series of the podcast and um
we deep dived into all of that I think
one thing that we and so it's so funny
we spent so much time trying to like
understand genetic testing and everyone
was like you don't need to do genetic
testing you don't need to do genetic
testing and the second she's born
they're like she has this horrible
genetic computation and we were like
okay but then they were also like no one
would have tested for it so we wouldn't
have known it I'm like what embroidered
it you know like what are you I mean if
it's early enough and you find out that
there's like this horrible debilitating
brain eating genetic mutation then yeah
just be an actor
she would she would have plenty of jobs
in Hollywood I'll hire her right now
she could run a studio
she could be my Asia
can I ask you about the panic attacks
yeah sure this is not something that I I
relate to but I feel like people throw
this around a lot people throw around I
get panic attacks I can panic attack and
it's like that's fair also people are
like I'm allergic to things and it's
like are you or do you just get a tummy
tickle or do you are you gonna die or
are you just difficult yeah I think it's
just your personality I think you're
this is Darwinism not fit you gotta go
okay so you want to know about panic
attacks yes because I think a lot of
people think they're having them and I'm
like no that's just being a person in
the world I think there's also this kind
of War on anxiety where people like I
get anxiety it's like yeah there's
debilitating anxiety where you can't get
out of bed but sure a little anxiety is
good it helps you get out of a bad
relationship it helps you realize you
need to you know listen to your gut
maybe this is all information that your
body is for survival yes and then I see
people that are like I have anxiety and
they're on they're going in
antidepressant they go on do you know
some things well now you're really you
know gonna atrophy your ability to
tolerate discomfort and listen to your
gut so I just think it's such an
important thing to
I am a hoarder of this company's product
now it's called fast growing trees okay
breathe some life into your own backyard
with fastgrowingtrees.com this spring I
am so obsessed with this company you can
order trees for your yard you have to go
to those freaking nursery and fight with
a bunch of people over one avocado bud
that's gonna dry up and be a mess okay
I'm totally replanting my backyard
because in California there's no water
left not sure if you noticed things
Gavin from shade to fresh fruit to
privacy and all kinds of natural beauty
all kinds of Flora okay let
fastgrowingtrees.com help you plant your
dream garden with their expert advice
and fast reliable shipping
fastgrowingtrees.com they're plant
experts curate thousands of easy to grow
plant shrub and tree varieties for your
unique climate Meyer lemons which I just
ordered I got lemons I got I think
tangelo's uh I don't know if this will
get us demonetized but I got kumquats so
excited an avocado tree anyway you can
get Evergreens everything in between
happy plants happy home right sometimes
it's hard to know which plants are going
to do best that's no problem over here
because with fastgrowingtrees.com you
get customized recommendations based on
your specific needs and I need marijuana
plants I don't think they sell those I'm
just kidding JK JK I just do the poppies
and NyQuil plus their plant experts are
always available to help keep your
plants growing healthy through the
season and Beyond no more waiting in
long lines hauling heavy plants around
with fastgrowingtrees.com you order
online and your plants arrive at your
door in just a few days it's so wild I
was worried they like most places they'd
show up all dead and Ratchet my God they
were Lush and with fast growing trees 30
day alive and Thrive guarantee you'll
know everything will look great fresh
out of the box join Over 1.5 million
happy fast growing tree customers go to
fastgrowingtrees.com Whitney now to get
15 off your entire order get 15 off at
fastgrowingtrees.com
Whitney fast growing trees from Fast
talking
cheese cheese
yeah I mean for me the thing that really
distinguishes between I'm having an
anxiety moment and I'm having a panic
attack moment is whether or not I can
breathe
um I I get a lot of pressure especially
on my chest and it makes it really
really difficult for me to breathe like
I'll try getting fake tits oh God
never these are like so big right now
that I can't stand them like me either
um but can I ask you is there is there's
a certain trigger that you can that is
kind of consistent it's just looking at
Twitter
um
I try to stay off of uh social media as
much watching me on Kimmel
um I think the thing that I that bothers
me the most is when I feel like someone
is not being honest with me so the whole
gaslighting thing again like I've been
gas lit to fucking hell yeah I know what
it looks like and when it's happening to
me I I go into a bad place and like I
understand why people are not always
totally honest with other people or they
become defensive or whatever it is like
I totally get it and at the same time
when it's happening to me it's really
hard
especially when it's someone close to me
I it's really hard for me to
in the moment just accept it for what it
is and give it the space that it needs
in order to unravel
um I try to when I feel like someone is
not being honest with me and then you
have to enter into their bullshit and
then you're like why are you making me
act and do bad improv why are you making
me do you think that it comes from
someone that thinks you're fragile and
they have to be
because that drives me nuts okay so
here's the thing I've had multiple
people tell me that they have to walk on
eggshells around me and I've been I do
make shakshuka a lot I think they're
literally so good
um but it's like no I I
I've I'm just letting you know that like
a thing happened and this is how I feel
about it and now we can move on together
with that knowledge and instead I'm told
well basically it's like your feelings
are unreasonable and I'm not going to
like acknowledge or accept your feelings
about whatever it is that may have taken
place and I'm like of all the people in
the world like I am actually the least
person that you have to walk on
eggshells around because I am super
tolerant of everything but if something
does bother me I'm not going to be weird
and passive aggressive about it I'm not
going to be conflict avoidant I'm just
going to let you know yeah and then and
then you can do without what you want
and I'll get over it no matter how you
respond to it but like just don't tell
me that it didn't happen
so I this happened when my mom died in
in December and she was in a bed for 11
years she had had a stroke it was like I
had great I I feel in a weird way lucky
that I got to grieve in like increments
whereas I see so many people that just
lose a parent suddenly and it's just
like you didn't get to say I love it you
didn't get to say I got to say
everything I needed to say I got to show
her the kind of woman that she made you
know I got to it's a really positive way
of looking at that good for you it's you
know my mom had a lot of I was able to
forgive her before she passed I was able
to you know caretaking her I was you
know I spent 10 years in hospitals when
I was on tour I'd go from hospital to
hospital it made me a very competent
person it's like
I see it as all the ways she wasn't able
to parent me as a child and give me the
skills I needed her being in hospitals
and nursing homes like that gave it to
me so it was a
it was an unfortunate way that she put
me in situations where I was able to
become a competent person I'm talking to
doctors all day you know I had to start
learning about Neuroscience I ended up
incorporating that into my work I made a
movie about it like it kind of like you
know even though it was unfortunate I
was able to you know sublimate it into
something that made me stronger the ways
that she couldn't make me strong on her
own this came this got into the female
brain that's why I wrote in the first
place because both my parents had
strokes and I'm 27 years old doctors are
like here's the where the the bleed is
in the hippocampus I don't know what the
fuck they're saying they're speaking you
know Latin and I'm like they're asking
I'm power of attorney so I have to make
all these huge decisions I have no idea
what's that and then you know their
personalities change a little bit based
on where the bleed is so I'm trying to
learn about you know what's going on and
um and then I got kind of obsessed I
discovered that a book called the female
brain and about sort of the differences
between the male and female brain I know
we don't believe in gender anymore but
there is some that can be very helpful
just in terms of a lot of the ways that
that women and men to men are manage
stereotype too we call them stupid like
that's you know men are objectified too
like women are objectified yeah we send
men to war just to die yeah so um uh I
uh
for so long you know was told like
you're crazy you're psycho whatever and
then you're like oh wait a second this
is just adrenaline and cortisol and my
amygdala didn't develop proper neural
Pathways with my hippocampus in front of
low because I was so adrenalized my
whole you know just learning it helped
me have more patience with myself and
not just accept this narrative you know
women are crazy women are psycho it's
like well we're wired to have to protect
you know babies in the woods in the dark
with no street lights so yeah we're a
little hyper Vigilant you know in the in
the you know new who's texting you used
to be what's that noise is that a lion
you know so it's we're sort of over
evolved for to live in a very dangerous
environment but now we you know they
comes out of their ways um and so
um what am I saying so oh so she passes
away I had a lot of notice
um it was almost like Groundhog Day like
every day this is the day she's gonna
but you know she'll be always in and out
of the year and I couldn't convince
people I was okay like it was this I had
people showing up at my house like
because I was like actually in a weird
way it was kind of freeing she wasn't
suffering anymore I didn't have to see
her in this you know there's a big
people don't talk a lot about like sick
parents and I think most people can't
afford the you know the nursing homes
are so so expensive not only so
expensive also
people that work there are underpaid her
teeth were being taken it was like she
had infections in her mess so I had to
go brush her T I had to go do a lot of
the stuff you know and um there was and
I think it was the second hand
embarrassment and shame like no one
really tells you about you know like
having to parent your parents yep is all
around just
and we get like weirdly like oh my God
it's gross like their body and like it's
it's it's decomposing in front of my
eyes and like I don't know how to deal
with that and am I allowed to touch that
and like they're literally in diapers
yeah they become children and the role
is completely reverse and you know it's
I think that for the most part our life
expectancy used to be so we it's just
very it's new that we get to that point
you know and so um
so there was a weird I was actually kind
of relieved and then uh I literally that
I didn't have to see her suffer anymore
and that we weren't just in this because
she was she got to the point a couple
years ago where she was like please come
I mean it was like it was so hard and um
I was sneaking her weed tincture and
that's nice because most uh you know
most patients I guess are they're giving
them Oxycontin and all this shit that
just makes them zombies you know she
doesn't want to deal they just want to
sedate them and so in January I almost
like went through like a Mania in a way
because I had so much energy and
bandwidth because I wasn't in this
constant you know I didn't have this
damn sword hanging of like What's it
gonna be this week and you know and she
would sort of because of the stroke had
it was almost like an OCD compulsion
she'd call me 50 times you know she just
was lonely and you know just the stress
of am I being a good enough daughter
whatever and I also had this like and so
many people were like you're you need to
see someone you need to these people
tried to put me on Seroquel which is
this like set it like I was like I'm
it's a big thing the happiest thing ever
I've been since she's been you know
because I don't have to think about her
suffering and I can now like kind of
enjoy her more now knowing you know and
gave her this incredible hospice like I
mean we went out by the ocean and you
know I didn't like push her
there was a house
[Laughter]
they're actually mentioned in Hunt
gather parent by the way this is a book
that I I I'm obsessed with it it's like
changed my life anyway would you say
yeah let's talk about that in one second
because um I started listening to it
just because I think it's never to
whether you have a kid or not like
reading about parenting stuff it's just
like honestly it's like let me allow me
to understand how to manage just people
in general because people are just
fucking children that's right so anyway
all five we're just tall kids I mean I
feel like you're an expert in managing
people anyway but like that's to me
that's why I love having mom's on sets
working because when someone has a
tantrum which usually comes from someone
feeling insecure or criticized or you
know people's brains are wired
differently differently and there's a
lot everyone's everyone's just trying
hard and if they feel criticized neglect
whatever something falls through the
cracks and and you know we kind of just
recreate our childhood circumstances on
a set you know I become people's moms or
their ex-wife or whatever the fuck we
all just like projection festival and um
moms when people start fighting or
freaking out or just like do you need
some water you need a snack
it's the same as again anger is just
sadness like someone's feeling
criticized or rejected you know and it's
kind of that simple so for me when
someone's upset I usually the first
thing I do is sit down so that I'm lower
than them and just fucking listen most
people just like need to be heard and
you just and then that's enough that's
honestly just enough just be like okay I
exist I'm a person in front of you
and then instead of going well here's
what we're going to do it's like what do
you think the solution should be yeah
and usually they're like well I just I
just think
you know I'm good and you're like you
just needed to be heard yep it's like
Valerie cherish in the comeback my
favorite show ever she was always like I
just need to know I'm being hurt and um
you know and yeah getting like lower
than them and just like softening your
voice and just visit because so much of
the communication is non-verbal and then
someone usually is feeling criticized
and then if they come to you because
they need something you're like well I
think you're overreacting they're just
you're just exacerbating yeah no you're
making it worse you know it's like sit
listen appreciate that sounds hard tell
me more about that what could we do to
make this you know smoother just asking
them questions you know and that's I
think I think yeah I think a lot of
people you know leadership is is a
tricky thing because I think a lot of
people think they need to be like
dominating and they you know but like
the alpha sleeps the alpha allows other
people you know so yeah also let people
figure stuff out oh yeah you know
absolutely like and you don't need to
overreact like I was gonna say the the
sort of lesson from the Inuits and
they're definitely not going to attack
you for calling them they send their
Elders out on an ice float to die okay
I'm not cow Towing on y'all's Integrity
but like the thing that they do is it's
like like temper tantrums like toddler
Tantrums don't exist there because it's
like they're freezing well it's your
modeling Behavior like the idea that a
human like an adult human would have a
tantrum is just absurd to them funny
like that some like an adult would raise
their voice at a child because like the
child is misbehaving is like it just
doesn't compute like culturally it's
like that's a dumb thing to do because
that human being doesn't know how to
like be a person yet they're still
figuring it out children children
exactly so if you're a child yeah you'll
have a tantrum but then you as the adult
are going to model the behavior which is
not having a tantrum and the idea that
an adult would have a tantrum is just
like if someone then calls around you
know adults that cried and had big
feelings and had Tantrums I remember
like I remember very few things from my
childhood but things I remember crystal
clear I remember seeing my mom cry and
have my watch divorce fighting furniture
back and forth you know just really
acrimonious shit and I remember going
I'm the I remember thinking like I'm the
adult yeah this is I don't get to do
that yep I never cried I never had shit
because I was like these are the
children and I'm the adult yeah I
remember it I would walk to school I
would make my lunch I caught on fire
because I stood on top of the stove I
was like trying to cut like I just was
like I'm on my own and I think when
children see adults acting like children
that's the natural like default yeah how
am I gonna rely on these people that or
they think that the only way to interact
with the world is by having tantrums and
I think that that is to me like the
lowest form of trying to get some kind
of power or something because it's like
you're trying to cry or show that You're
vulnerable so the other person pities
you so that you get what you want or
you're not in control of your emotions
which is like how can I have any respect
for you if you can't control your um
emotions and yeah I think like as
someone who is not always the best at
controlling one's emotions I do
appreciate when someone has patience
with me but also it's not an excuse It's
not like just because you're crying
doesn't mean you're right
you can say I mean there's again tools
that I have that are like when I find
myself trust me around January February
March when I was because the grief did
come the anger came I had a lot of anger
come up after my my mom died because I
was angry that I had lost my whole kind
of half of my 20s and 30s to sick
parents the anger of like why the fuck
didn't you guys take care of yourselves
right why did you have strokes without
health insurance Strokes the most
preventable fucking thing on the planet
you could have just gotten blood
pressure medication I come from the
generation of of people that go like I
don't want to go to the doctor because I
don't want to know yeah and so to me I
truly feel like if you want to be a
parent at some point it starts now
because if you're not taking care of
yourself now your children are gonna
have to take care of you when they're in
their 20s and 30s and that is so fucking
unfair so I just was like angry that I
didn't get to have like fun in my late
20s and 30s and I was paying for their
care and I was like fucking working my
ass off doing like weird corporate gigs
for like businessmen and fucking Park
City to pay for sure that was fun
the Saudis love me
um I do very well in Dubai
um uh and so I was just so resentful and
I didn't realize how much anger I had
and I think that I did use humor to cope
so much that I I um I did never feel the
anger and I realized like I I have to
get angry and Rick Rubin actually wrote
a book
um in one of the exercises he has in it
about creativity is just
it sounds ridiculous and it's
embarrassing but what's more
embarrassing than not being able to
control your temper because some old if
it's hysterical it's historical shit
comes up you punch a pillow for five
minutes straight
and it's exhausting and something about
exhausting yourself that much and even
emulating anger that you might not even
have it's like you know when they say
that scream therapy or whatever they do
yeah 100 yeah and the Smashing stuff
therapy which I actually wrote and uh
have you ever seen those like rage rooms
I've seen them in like shows but so I
wanted I wrote as a cold open for a
pilot once about this character was
based on me
um and uh just my you know whatever
neurosis and it's um she goes into a
rage room and people are watching and
there's a glass and it's you know it's
TVs and VCRs and old bookcases it's just
a bunch of like trash you know and you
basically go and you just like Smash It
and people are watching like her two
friends and they're like wincing and
like oh God like watching my character
in The Rage room and then I come out and
then you reverse and she's just
organized all of it perfectly
I feel so much better thank you oh my
god there was a mess in there it feels
so much better double Virgo over here
that's all I really needed there's also
have you ever seen The Scream painting
the yeah the the one where they they're
going the like drawn out face with the
long oh yes oh my gosh it's your two
area diet for me
um uh yes that's the the monk painting
but I'll send it to you it's this guy
it's um he's painting as he screams and
he's just like ah I'll send it to you
it's it's so did he have a video yes
that sounds exhausting it's a very small
candy
different regular
ly so pugnacious for no reason but uh
and I'm punching this pillow and
punching this pillow and I just started
sobbing and then
it's hard to make yourself cry if you've
spent most of your life trying to not
cry yeah try not to be vulnerable in
front of other people yeah and then
you're like well I guess I just need to
cry I need to grieve you're like how I
don't know how to do this like I've I've
mastered the art of just you know
um uh and and then you write out
everything you're angry about and I
could not believe the kind of stuff that
was coming out it's very like it's it's
almost like a Ouija board like it starts
coming out the things I was angry at was
so things I haven't thought about in
years there's something about the anger
just like unlocking all the things I had
repressed that I was pissed off about I
literally got to like sun in the hair
stuff you know remember sun in yeah
absolutely I was like my hair was orange
blonde there was a lot of stuff I have
an older sister who's blonde and there
was a lot of like I'm angry I wasn't
blonde like yeah what the fuck that's a
weird God I love it so it's so funny I
love journaling so I've been doing this
practice of trying to do
um three pages of journaling a day like
you just give yourself
however much time it takes but like you
just do it you just do you don't stop
it's almost like stream of conscious
three pages fill three pages and I'm
constantly surprised by how much stuff
I'm pissed off about that just comes out
that I'm like I didn't even know I was
pissed off about that I hate journalists
this is so fucking boring yeah like and
it just it just practices the I think
art of processing something as soon as
you feel it and then putting it out and
so you don't like have it weirdly
harboring inside of you and becoming a
weird resentment that came out of
nowhere while you're having lunch with
your husband like I think we just on a
uh
like have just there's so much coming at
us all the time to be pissed off about
and we just have to compartmental I
don't have time to be upset about it
don't and then we go numb but I think to
me that's how I actively resist going
numb is like I'm pissed about this all
these feelings are valid you wouldn't
tell a child if a child was like I'm
upset that you know this is you wouldn't
go like shut up put that away you'd be
like oh let's solve that let's talk
through that but as adults we're just
like no time yeah get over it get over
it get over here and I think that the
word empath I think is so overused but I
think that you know when you're the type
of person where things hurt like I
struggle being in New York because in
airports because you just feel of
people's stuff like you feel their pain
you feel you know and I um I really I
feel like I take on that and then you
know another tool that's really helped
me in addition
um to writing you know just writing
stuff out with no judgments I used to
really have so much perfectionism of
like I couldn't this is so embarrassing
but that's what we do on this podcast
um
uh
I used to really struggle journaling
because I always was like someone's
gonna read this one day yeah so I'd be
like I hear you it is so hard you know
like like I need to write with my
perfect person Ryan Reynolds keeps
calling and I don't know if I'm
interested you know what I mean I just
feel like I wanted the handwriting to be
perfect I wanted it to be like the
perfect Journal you know you know we did
that to actual people in the past like
people just went like oh yeah this guy's
letters that were totally meant to be
private like I mean obviously was really
good friends with Gary Shandling but it
was like all his journals I was like
whoa my God is somebody gone through my
journal one day this is my like
nightmare so I was like I've been
cutting pasting stuff out of like
Teenage magazines of like cute little
outfits in my freaking Journal like I
don't look at that Harry Styles and I on
top of a wedding cake together this is
not okay they're gonna I'm gonna lose
custody of my kids one day if someone
finds this you know and I would like
start it and then I would rip the pad
but then I start over I think also
something that a big mistake I made with
journaling is I started doing on the
computer I was like I'm gonna type out
my journal it's such a bad no I think
it's about like the magic of what comes
out and then you put it away yeah no but
I I'm definitely with you like I've
absolutely started journal entries being
like I swear I'm not an angry person
I swear I'm actually really happy and
like he's the same like I'm gonna have
like I'm gonna tell I'm gonna go out of
my way all the things I'm grateful for
but then let me just you know if you put
a little gold flakes in a man's coffee
it'll kill him instantly I know I'm just
like this feels like future evidence in
a court case like this I can't admit
that you know I can't admit this to
myself I can't say this out loud and
that's what you're supposed to do
because I feel like just this it really
helped me combat my perfectionism and
also something that that really really
helped me because you know whether this
isn't it is what it is it works for me
to say like my inner child you know if
I'm having a bad reaction to something
if I'm crying it's like obviously it
could be about the situation at hand you
know but chances are it's something has
activated some old feelings that I never
felt or I felt like I wasn't allowed to
feel right didn't want to have the big
feelings like that were in my household
I was like this is exhausting this is
like not interested and um
an inner child exercise it's actually in
the adult child of Alcoholics book which
is a program that I'm in which is it's
not that you're an alcoholic you don't
say your parents are an alcoholic for
alcoholism to be present alcohol doesn't
have to be present it's any kind of
compulsive Behavior that's not a choice
our you know whether our parents were
actually drinking which most were like
that was the Mad Men generation this is
like the first generation that isn't
having three martinis at lunch you know
we're having three Edibles at lunch now
um or we're on our phones it looks yeah
addictions look to phones now that's you
know and so um the inner child exercise
which is you in your right hand you ask
your child a couple questions you can
literally say everything from what do
you want to eat today what do you want
to do this weekend
um you know what's who's your best
friend and then you uh well you write
that in your dominant hand right and
then you respond in your non-dominant
hand fascinating and it's an incredible
exercise that has like changed my life
because you go like oh my best friend is
this person and this person and you're
adult and then you write your child and
all of a sudden it's like someone you're
like it's my dog
really well that is the truth
um and or it's someone that you like
don't really see that much like why
don't I see that person more like but I
obviously care about them like a safe
person that's like maybe not someone you
work with because we're so like I need
to get this work done this person you
know whatever this is a person that fits
in my life right now whatever and you're
like yeah let me reach out to that
person from high school that I had such
a you know or um you know it's like what
do you want to eat today the adult's
gonna go I need to eat this and this and
I have to have the kale and I have to
this and a mine is always peanut butter
and jelly I'm like why don't I just make
myself a fucking peanut butter and jelly
sandwich what is why am I hurt torturing
myself with these delicious I'm not
gonna say meals yes how about these door
decks deliveries but yeah totally I'm
like why am I you know like and so it's
something that's really helped because I
think we forgot to kind of nurture our
inner child because especially as
someone that I was like so insecure
about not being mature enough or not
being an adult enough especially being
in a business where you can stay you can
Peter Pan through your hole you can stay
immature forever and it's actually
rewarded by audiences oh you're a mess
oh you can't get it together yeah
like oh like I should stay a mess this
is really working you know so it's just
like a good way to kind of like connect
with sort of the your more um primary
you're more sort of
say childish that's so nice I said the
fact that childish is a negative
adjective is so interesting because
children are so much smarter there's so
much like when they're sad they cry when
they're want something they ask when
they're sleepy they sleep
at least if you let them can I ask a
couple things about that and then I know
I have to let you go because you're
going to you're on your own podcast con
today
um in terms of I see these parents that
put their parent perfectionism on their
kids you have to sleep at this time and
I have a sleep schedule and I have this
and like it feels like you're really
doing you know allowing the kid to be a
kid
yeah so I mean I think that part of the
reason why like this schedule became
such a sacred object in the parenting
world
um is in large part because so many of
us are slaves to the schedule that we're
a part of and so we have to make our
children a slave to a schedule so that
we can function in the world
um and I don't think that that actually
is to the benefit of any of us I don't
think any of us are sleeping well I
don't think any of us are mentally
healthy and I and so when it comes to me
I try to avoid having to live by
schedules that exist in the outside
industrialized World
um and in the same way I want I want
Eureka and my children to to feel what
they need and to do what they need to do
to get what they need and so when she's
hungry she'll get food and when she's
sleepy she'll sleep I'm gonna tell you
one of the most and I won't say
traumatic whatever I'm a white woman
um so uh you know
I had the finish everything on your
plate or you can't leave um finish that
glass of milk I didn't pour the glass of
milk right a glass of milk I had that
too and yeah and I did have really
severe Eating Disorders I know there's a
lot of okay Moss was on the cover of
every magazine growing up I had sexual
abuse there was a lot of reasons that
I'm sure I had the the eating disorder
stuff but I look back at the you can't
leave until you finish everything on
your plate right it's not about how you
feel it's not how food has has like have
you enjoyed I'm five I'm full yeah I'm
full I'm ready to go also I didn't make
my plate yeah if if you're gonna make me
finish everything I'm gonna play could I
at least make it because I know what I'm
gonna finish yeah I remember sitting
there chugging milk just being like a
milk thing too just like why do we need
20 ounces of milk at everything only
drinking another species milk
it's just like your cake you just want
to watch a kid guzzle whites like I just
and I remember thick because then I um
you know you know Eating Disorders are
very much about control the only thing I
can control is what's in my body I can't
control what's going on around me I
can't control getting attention I can't
control you know my circumstances in an
alcoholic home you really can't control
when you sleep there's loud and you do
fall there's noises you're scared at
night you know that kind of thing and it
was sort of like it was the only thing I
could control and forcing kids to eat
when they don't want to eat I always
think it's just so wild and the other
thing that I think is a lie is that kids
need different food than adults do like
that's another lie that I've encountered
where like you have to get it feels like
Gerber was pushing that yeah big baby is
a big thing big baby is definitely
pushing a lot of lies um I just have
I've always just given Eureka what we
were eating and
um even when she didn't have teeth I
would just chew it for her and stick it
in her mouth
um we're animals yeah that's how we were
meant to exist that like human beings
have survived for before Gerber yeah
yeah and and
the dark part of this is your child
would be perfect on the cover of those
babies I need to do you have a gerber
baby I know and I don't put her on the
internet but like I've had people I've
actually had a casting person he like
just happened to see her once and they
were like uh give me that child I was
like I don't want to give you my job but
also I kind of don't want to give you my
job like uh are you gonna turn her into
a face cream
and I would not get them involved it is
crazy I mean I gotta say is my favorite
movie being Labyrinth which you all of
course know it does haunt me a little
bit because I do re-watch it quite often
and uh
Toby the baby is crying the whole movie
and as an adult you look back and you're
like uh
how did they shoot this scene I mean
yeah no I I feel you I I'm I don't think
if I were ever to put my ridiculously
beautiful baby in any kind of
professional capacity it would be for
like the shortest commercial ever and it
would be the only thing that I would
ever have her do and then I would give
her all the money that ever came from it
yeah and it's like yeah I mean it's uh
that you put it in a trust yeah put it
in something and when she's like how
could you put me you're like
do you have a condo or do you have a car
you mean so I because of that you got to
sleep whenever you wanted so we didn't
have to have a sleep schedule for you I
mean there was I've worked on things
where there's a baby on set and I'm like
can't we just get a Toys R Us like we're
not zooming in on that we don't get you
know and they'd be like get the Benadryl
and you're like whoa they would put
Whiskey on there and gums was the whole
thing it's it's when you look back
you're like the baby is being too much
of a baby I need to do baby I mean
imagine a baby just in I mean I would
have been in heaven uh uh around all the
Jim Henson goblins just like man man
what babe like just like David Bowie's
Cod piece like flopping around and the
baby's just like like if you see it you
that baby is right that's it's been
crying for a while oh my God they were
like the goblin continuity issue take
again I mean I'm sure and you've seen
that movie they were all on LSD dude
they were just like that's not a real
baby is it
um so when you look back please tell me
that's a muppet but I'm also kind of
babies in movies toddlers they don't
really know what they're yeah doing but
I think it's odd that child labor is a
legal yet child acting
is a thing I just think it's odd when
you're 10 to
18 you should you know what I mean like
I I hear you I I mean and I'm not like I
don't even know exactly what it's like
to be on set like you know this way
better than I do but it does sound like
it's long hours and a lot of pressure
I've said it every episode and I'll say
it again uh this is a business built on
the back of a five-year-old toddler
named Shirley Temple and I my whole the
cause is Justice for Shirley Temple
because if she was starring in movies at
four that means they casted it to shot
it at three
like and if she got the job that means
like a hundred other toddlers auditioned
and they went like too ugly no
costume fittings for like dance monkey
dance dance monkey dance not there's not
a mom in the movie there's no babysitter
there's no stepmom she's just at War
with soldiers like I age when I I
sometimes like really get in a wormhole
and I just she's in blackface in one of
the movies like Justin Trudeau level
blackface and no one's mad it drives
some fucking nuts
um and then there was have you seen Good
Ship Lollipop no
I've not seen these Shirley Temple
movies I don't know if you should I mean
this is this is we can't we're just fine
with this Chris we're just everyone's
fine with this that is straight up shoe
polish to the eye line I mean and yeah
Good Ship Lollipop she's on a train with
all these men like dancing for them like
flirty which means there was a good
choreographer who was like yeah shake
your to the costumer I'm like there was
that customer I am coming for you and
you're off like I am they made these
little mini skirts and then her diaper
underneath like matched it's like why
isn't she wearing pants like that's the
other thing about this whole
conversation about you know babies
transitioning and toddlers little girls
want to dress as little boys and I'm
like can I think little boys and little
girl no one should dress like little
girls
no one we don't stop making little mini
skirts for girl with them yeah you know
just all they should all dress like boys
until they're 21.
okay no it's practical no one should
dress like a little girl not even a
little girl I don't like any of this
shit you know
um but yeah and then I mean that
conversation it's like I'm working on
this in my new hour and I'm gonna get
torn apart by it but it's like the
two-year-old's transition it's like I
grew up poor like when you grow up poor
you're whatever gender your older
sibling was like you don't get to pick
it's just yeah whatever was there yeah
do you do a lot of clothing swaps with
oh I don't yeah I I have a lot of
friends who have kids and I just inherit
everything and I just take everything I
have so many clothes actually I should
like it's I try I'm like trying to give
people clothes that's awesome yeah
that's awesome because I feel like
that's another thing people get so
resentful for their kid because they're
spending so much money on them so stop
buying your kids no prom dresses just
ask your friends for their old napkins
or some shit really quick I know I have
to let you go to go do trash Tuesday
what are you working on am I allowed to
ask uh at the next yeah so um so Logan
wants to know Rogan wants to know very
invested
actually I think Rogan might be
interested in what we're doing right now
we have this whole series called so in
Labyrinth we have another mini series
that we've done that's um called blood
money and it's all about like the
history and ethics of True Crime so if
you spent like two years working on this
project and like talking to all the
people and all the people who are
invested and so it's it's it's good I
think that's a crazy question sorry
about the Dahmer show the Dahmer show
which I haven't seen but it is it is
scripted about Jeffrey Dahmer right
what do you make of that I mean people
got very upset about it I mean it's like
I'm just curious what you think about
like these endless stock endless movies
about
um
I think what the argument really is is
like you're sanitizing these killers or
making them hot or sexy casting these
hot like Zac Efron playing Ted Bundy so
I know that one because I've seen that
one and I remember
um talking to Joe Berlinger about this
actually
um because I I I'm pretending I know who
that is
um so he for people who don't he also
did
um the he's he's first of all he's the
director of that Zac Efron thing but he
also did the documentary about Ted Bundy
and um so they did this sort of
companion piece thing where there was a
documentary about Ted Bundy and then
they had the Zac Efron movie about Ted
Bundy and the whole point he said about
doing the Zac Brown movie was to show
that Ted Bundy was charming and that's
one of the ways that he was able to
victimize people and he wanted to show
the perspective of this woman who had
been His companion for years without
realizing what he was doing and so he
wanted to like do you think he
intentionally had her as like an alibi
type thing or do you think he genuinely
I I don't know like he I don't know how
to get into the mind of that person
yeah I'm asking literally the wrong by
the way I'm like that's what he was
doing and someone who probably will kill
someone in my lifetime it because do you
know Jenna Friedman the comedian
Jennifer yeah no she's a good friend of
mine she did a series
um what was it called
um uh it was on uh YouTube it's so funny
we were just talking about it here when
she was here last week she was here last
night yeah um and she uh it's a parody
remember the New York Times
um marriage announcements that were on
whatever New York Times it was like rich
people like walking around the city it
was just like so whatever elitist like
nonsense and it was Ted people who
mattered it was yeah it was Ted Bundy
Ted and Gracie and it's like a comedic
take on on this you know she's obsessed
with murderers and stuff but um but yeah
like it it
part of the reason that women fall in
love with men in prison too like
murderers yeah the the the sense of
control over the relationship because
clearly can't cheat on you right and
also like they're really dependent on
you in a lot of ways
um I that's what I've I've heard like
what at Ted Bundy's hearings weren't
like girls showing up and girls were
yeah so I think that when I was talking
to Joe Berlinger about this he said that
his specific goal in talking about this
was in re was in response to this sort
of glamorization that was happening at
the time which was like trying to
acknowledge like here was a person who
was using his charm and he was drawing
in people to believe in him as he was
like you know grandiose trying to make
his case that he's not a guy who just
like fucks skulls and like and and
um and it was working and that's the
problem and so that's why he he
specifically wanted someone like Zac
Efron because he was like girls are
throwing themselves at Zac Efron they
were literally throwing themselves at
Ted Bundy and so I've seen some of his
movies he is getting away with murder
um but no I think that's actually a
really
incisive point because you know as uh my
therapist says charm is a red flag
number one and as Gavin debecker says in
the gift of fear which if you haven't
read it I hate your guts I recommend it
every episode about women and um you
know uh they say 99 of women uh the one
percent that that you know don't are too
traumatized to even speak that in there
what would you call it your exit
interview after being attacked and raped
your post-wrap up your employee review
whatever say I knew there was something
off about that guy I knew it like they
just didn't trust their gut because the
guy was so charming and he offered to
carry their groceries and he probably a
door for them and da da like there is
something about someone being so helpful
and so Charming it gaslights you into
believing like why am I why would I ever
question yeah exactly like I had
somebody feels off but I'm such a
narcissist like I'm so you know why
can't I accept a little chivalry why
like why do I why am I so paranoid why
am I so you know so why would this you
know and and it's that charm that
actually makes us over
you know uh uh override our gut instinct
there's something off about this guy but
like what kind of asshole am I that I
can't just accept some chivalry right
right right I'm broken yeah like the
guy's just trying to be nice what's
wrong with you and they they're like oh
let me open the door for you to carry
your groceries in and then they closed
it and it's that's the deal so charm is
like you know I think people tend to see
it's I I'm on his side now um not that I
had a side before but I think that's a
really smart point because I think most
of us think of you know the guy I'm
dating you've met him everyone's like ah
this guy's a little like the person that
looks like they would be the is usually
not the person you know what I mean if
you're gonna go around being a a a bad
person you're not gonna dress like my
guy you're not he dresses like a school
shooter I'm like this but those are the
people he really does he really does
there's a lot of camo there's so much
it's it's shirts from Amazon where did
he go to high school yeah it's by the
way it's the Mohawk mullet it'll really
get you I'm like can you maybe just go
out in the sun for maybe 20 minutes can
we not be this pale
um but uh but I think that you know we
tend to go and I see it all the time
with you know quote-unquote stalkers and
people that come to my shows Robin's
like ah that person looks I'm like nah
dude it's not gonna be that guy it's
gonna be the Charming guy that has the
gift who's like you know making
everybody like him who finds the access
who figures out a way to get close to
somebody that's the person you have to
worry about the person you would never
suspect you know it's like they say like
like and when someone sends a death
threat like you know Gavin Decker always
says like that's not the person you have
to worry about because the person that's
going to do something bad to you is not
going to give you a heads up right right
right yeah I know that's true that's
what the FBI always told me when I
brought my death threats to them
they were with some weird explicit ones
too but you're like but I just this it
feels like I need to tell someone about
this yeah no absolutely like I'm just
like I'm not no one's ever described
like fucking me while electrocuting me
to death before so I just like who do I
talk about that I can't breathe I'm very
flattered yeah
um because someone's been in jail very
honored someone's willing that's what I
always do I'm like someone's not gonna
go to jail for me also can you imagine
killing me and then I have a row a
double
like you like I have a robot just the
idea of just like is that why you have
the room you're gonna kill the only girl
that has a double like
um but uh but also something that really
blew not blew my mind but just along
these lines of the person that I have in
my life that actually is a danger uh
more to others um is a woman
is a woman and that's a tricky one to to
with security to be like this per and
then they're like that's a girl and
you're like that's the same thing it's
like oh it's Ted Bundy it's a great
hairline right he's wearing Abercrombie
khakis don't what like just the things
that we've sort of for whatever reason
movies
Etc
been you know convinced ourselves is not
the stereotype of what someone dangerous
would look like sure sure because I feel
like that isn't their behavior I feel
like he got a lot of shit for that movie
he did absolutely he did and that was
the beginning of people like giving
people shit for doing movies that
made a character out of what we want to
think is simply a monster and I think
that
it's a tricky question like it's not
clear I think there's there's intention
there's execution there's a world in
between
um there's how people are receiving it
there's whether or not the actual
victims of the person were consulted
um there's those kinds of issues
um because like I can't tell you the
number of times that people have said
like I didn't know that there was going
to be a film where I'm a character in it
until it came out that was a big one in
um the Dahmer one yeah and if you're
gonna do it pay me
like give me the option to
right you know and also it's like yeah
the Dahmer guy a lot of it was like he's
such a daddy he's so hot and that's when
you're like was that the narrative about
him I don't actually know that much
about Dahmer was that like a thing he's
I mean like I mean look it's hard to
find an actor that's not going to be hot
and symmetrical and right you know
whatever emotionally unavailable and
he's very strong he was able to put I
mean you know but um but yeah I do think
there's also just that that sneaky part
of our you know nature where whether
it's you know with an obsession with
True Crime whether it's our our
primordial brain wanting to do research
like you know it's like looking at a car
crash it's like yeah they say it's to to
research what to not do yeah um or what
to worry about or if it's just straight
up adrenaline turns into dopamine and
things you know we watch horror movies
we sign up to get scared right you know
we love a puzzle it makes dry exactly it
makes adrenal well this we know how it's
going to end we know how Dahmer's gonna
end we've known the end of it but we
just want to watch the The Addictive
yeah the addictive nature of it I mean I
remember watching mine hunter and being
like so mad because I felt like and look
he told the story I think the it's David
Fincher I mean this is brilliant but it
felt like every narrative was like well
it's the mom's fault for not letting him
wear a pantyhose it felt like every
murder every psychopath is like has a
bad mom is there like even a show about
that that's like it shows like it just
traces everything back to the mom well
where was the dad if there was a dad
around maybe the mom wouldn't have like
had to be the only you know influence in
his life but yeah it felt like every
serial killer in the mom if the mom had
just let him wear her heels we wouldn't
be in this Jam I mean or like it just it
felt a little bit like you know but um
but you know who know I did do you think
that the True Crime obsession is the our
brain doing research or or like
adrenaline addiction thing I mean I
think that it has been a part of our
psychology for way longer than we want
to think we want to think that like True
Crime is this like new phenomenon that
we're all obsessed with but like the
Romans we would go sign up go to a
Coliseum and watch people die slowly
exactly like this is super historical I
think that it's
um I think we're all fascinated by our
own human nature we all want to
understand each other we want us to
understand dangers we want to solve
puzzles
um we want to feel like we have some
kind of control over a really chaotic
Universe
um and I think that part of True Crime
is that feeling of some kind of control
in a chaotic Universe
um so true but I think that the problem
is that it's become such a commodity and
like truly truly the worst experiences
of people's lives have become a
commodity that then comes to Define them
and there are so many people who have
been in positions like me or who have
been you know victims of crimes have
been exploited because by people in
Industries who are profiting off of it
profiting off of their pain and then
telling them things like this is your
chance to tell your story but then they
go and tell it however way they want and
meanwhile so then they get to walk away
from the experience with the money and
that person who has lived that
experience gets re-traumatized in a
whole new way so I feel like knowing how
the sausage gets made is really really
important and considering that there are
lived consequences that people deal with
should give us a better understanding of
the kind of things that we're consuming
just on a sort of guilty pleasure basis
yeah and I'm like I'm all for guilty
pleasure I I do have to minimize my
watching and I watch that killer Sally
documentary of the the woman the
bodybuilders and she you know these body
builders and they were insured they were
going to Tijuana getting these wild
steroids and then her bodybuilder
husband his friend had just killed had
like a rage and like killed his
girlfriend and he the this Sally's has
husband was beating her and she got a
gun and he she just knew she was like
he's gonna kill this is the night he's
gonna kill me
and he was beating or beating her she
grabbed the gun shot him in the back so
it's not self-defense they've gotta and
she was honest she was like yeah I
grabbed the gun as he turned around I
shot him and then she went to jail
because it has for self-defense he's got
to be facing you or the person has to be
facing yeah and it was just like I was
watching it I was just like why am I
doing this to myself like I'm making I'm
getting addicted to this shit it is very
addicting I think that's that's
absolutely true there's also a little
bit of a little hit of superiority well
at least I'm not in this relationship
like you're just as little as if this is
what I need to feel Superior we really
gotta work or just a gratitude check
like oh God things could be so much
worse yeah just like the anger of like
the legal system like I would I don't
recommend you why because you're
watching how she's getting interrogated
and you're just she's just telling the
truth and it's just she's so fucked and
it's just watching her getting taken
away from her it's just like kind of a
um
what would you call that
um I don't uh it feels just like cutting
or something I don't know yeah I mean
it's weird how train wrecks and and
things unraveling just Fascinate human
yeah you're learning because I really
was like oh yeah if I need to shoot
someone who's attacking me I better I
better wait till they attack me again
you know it's just like and it's just
like someone in a shitty situation
things go sideway and you're just like
God damn it like it's just
yeah it makes me go like oh okay yeah
all right all right we survived this
yeah what okay so this is making me feel
a little bit better about you know
um accidentally tweeting my address on
only fans
um did you yes I did and honestly I will
say only fans fans because these are
people that are not they don't want your
work for free whereas I find on
Instagram on Twitter it's like this
wasn't funny and you shouldn't say this
well that's one of the big problems with
True Crime is like people feel entitled
to it and interesting and so I feel like
that is that's huge like it's not that
there aren't worthy stories to tell it's
just
[Laughter]
um no please and I'm gonna um and very
awkwardly per usual because it is 2 30
and you do have to go and I don't want
you guys to be rushing okay okay I love
you so much that I'm gonna actually cut
this off early
fully circumcising this
um I love you Amanda Knox Labyrinth um
uh I cannot wait to hear the yes the new
series is blood Money speaking of cannot
wait yeah I cannot wait I love you thank
you for doing this you can catch her on
the roast of Whitney Cummings um on only
fans TV it is free of.tv slash Whitney
slash roast or just go to OTV it's on
the homepage
um and uh I love you go I can't wait um
Labyrinth lovers it'll just make you so
much smarter when I listen to the
podcast I do have to look up words every
now and then oh shoot um it's good I
feel so much smarter
um I love you um thank you for doing
this absolutely you're the best okay
and you can catch on trash Tuesday also
yeah with the Maniacs all right love you
my way
[Music]